the Marvel Cinematic Universe might look
very different had the God of Thunder
not been put through the Rayner
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely explains that they had
to change their plans due to the radical
reinvention of Thor and director Tycho
itt's thor ragnarok fans of the MCU know
very well that ytt essentially
rehabilitated the character of Thor
after his somewhat lackluster portrayal
in the series prior to Ragnarok while
there were always humorous undertones to
the god of thunder ytt tapped into star
Chris Hemsworth's comedic chops to give
us a Thor who was just as quippy as his
fellow Avengers but if I'm being honest
when it comes to fighting beings he is
very powerful useful yeah van is
powerful and useful to see though the
hero's newly comedic personality felt
very different to his rather dour
demeanor in other MCU films which meant
that the early drafts of infinity war
needed to be adjusted to accommodate it
remember we had it we were inheriting a
Thor from Ragnarok who was very well and
radical eerie tone from the previous
Avengers movies
according to Markus and McFeely they
actually had to fly in Hemsworth and ytt
to make sure that the Odin sons
characterization made sense going from
Thor Ragnarok to Avengers infinity war
but why TT didn't just tweak the Thunder
gods characterization he put the poor
guy through the kind of narrative
gauntlet that few Marvel characters have
had to endure forcing him to experience
more loss in a single film than he ever
had before Markus and McFeely saw in
this an opportunity to portray Thor in a
novel almost shocking way in Avengers
infinity worth the Thunder God is
obviously still hurting from the events
of Ragnarok and in that Films opening
he's forced to witness the murder of his
adopted brother Loki as well as his
friend Heimdall at the hands of Thanos
during a later conversation with rocket
door seems withdrawn unsure of himself
insecure even depressed that continues
to the end of the film in which Thor
makes a crucial error failing to
immediately kill Thanos allowing the mad
Titan to snap away half of all life in
the universe the failure nearly breaks
the Thunder God and when we see him an
Avengers endgame he's despondent enough
over it to kill a defenseless Thanos in
the
opening moments Markus explained in thor
ragnarok he loses his kingdom his father
his sister and his eyeball
we just thought about what would happen
if any one of us sustained this loss and
horror
you would get incredibly depressed and
retreat from the world that is a comedic
performance with a lot of pain behind it
if ytt hadn't put Thor through the
wringer and Ragnarok it's safe to say
that Markus and McFeely s interpretation
of the character would have been very
different
considering how instrumental Thor's
failure and subsequent breakdown are to
the narrative of infinity war and
endgame it's possible that inheriting a
steadier more confident Odin son might
have changed the entire story that
Markus and McFeely were crafting for
that matter the dour King leaf dwarfed
his first two solo films almost
certainly wouldn't have made the choice
he did at the conclusion of endgame to
leave new Asgard in the hands of
Valkyrie and head out to go on
interstellar adventures with the
guardians of the galaxy this development
seems likely to affect the MC use
overarching narrative for years to come
writer director James Gunn's upcoming
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 will
certainly have to address it and Thor's
decision to leave earth behind is also
certain to play into the story of 2021 s
Thor 11th under the latter film we'll
see why TT returned to the franchise to
showcase Thor's former flame Jane Foster
picking up the hammer to become the
Mighty Thor indeed it's easy to make the
case that with Thor Ragnarok ytt didn't
just reinvent the word franchise he
shook up the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's also pretty amazing that
Markus and McFeely were able to
incorporate the adjustments while also
constructing the most complex narrative
the franchise has ever seen and still
cracked the story for the
highest-grossing movie in history check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bells so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]